non le dr okumu de sa race protoss part
un premier filet notre chat ou sur le
site mort né ou krajina or la schl a
béni ce n'est pas l'ukraine dans qui a
choisi le la voie de la guerre l'ukraine
veut la paix ce travail tu dois je vous
appelle vous dire à rejoindre les rangs
de nos combattants ce
vide votre expérience militaire est
extrêmement important tout dépend de
vous
l'indépendance de notre pays dépend de
vous tha
nous
avons besoin des donneurs du sang
s'il vous plaît et des mains pour
pouvoir assurer
la vie dans nos vies le moïse chacun
d'eux va prendre soin de ses proches du
dossier
journaliste il nous faut également des
journalistes il est important de
défendre notre liberté
aujourd'hui je me suis entretenu avec
des représentants de l'union européenne
et de la polonia 2 le triche et doutre
payer si
vous
cher leader européen j leader et les
dirigeants du monde libre si vous ne
nous aidez pas
l'ukraine aujourd'hui demain la guerre
sera chez vous glos